mais d'abord à l'image de la situation
en france la campagne de vaccination
contre le coc vide 19 est à la peine en
touraine pour l'instant selon la rs
seule une cinquantaine de patients
étaient vaccinés dans les ehpad dans un
instant on ira plus loin sur le
calendrier avec mon invité la
responsable du centre de vaccination du
chru de tours mais d'abord cette
nouvelle étape donc à partir de demain
et les soignants de plus de 50 ans pour
ôter eux aussi se faire vacciner alors
et ont un tournant lucas chopin avec
aurélie renault il faut enclencher la
vitesse supérieure
c'est le message que s'accordent à faire
passer les professionnels de santé au
sujet de leur vaccination
philippe paganelli et le président du
conseil de l'ordre des médecins d'indre
et loire
et pour lui cette vaccination présente
un double intérêt
d'une part parce que c'est eux qui
doivent soigner les gens donc c'est
quand même important qu'ils sont en
bonne santé si si il n'y a plus de
pilote dans l'avion avant l'avion il va
pas il va pas voler le bien loin et la
deuxième chose pour l'exemplarité de la
chose il faut absolument que les
médecins se fassent vacciner et montrent
qu'ils n'ont qu'ils ont confiance dans
ce vaccin et qu'on pourra sortir de
cette pandémie grâce au vaccin
ce retard au démarrage dans la campagne
de vaccination dans le pays s'explique
notamment par la difficulté à
comptabiliser le nombre de vaccins
nécessaires aux ehpad
la france a décidé d'avoir un avis
éclairé et d'un avis signé par le
patient
d'autres pays ont choisi d'autres voies
là il faut un avis signé donc c'est plus
long les résidents ne sont pas forcément
au fait de tous et le médecin doit ré
expliquer la totalité
pourquoi la vaccination qu'est-ce que ça
entraîne d'ici la fin de la semaine 500
patients et personnels d pad devrait
être vaccinés dans la région soit dix
fois plus que la semaine dernière la
montée en charge elle se fait dès cette
semaine d'indre et loire a commencé la
vaccination la semaine dernière mais
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à la fin du
moins avoir vacciné sur l'ensemble de la
région donc ça vaut pour l'indre et
loire évidemment l'ensemble des états
concernés les projets le souhait
continuer pour le moment près de dix
mille doses de vaccins sont disponibles
en indre et loire
l' agence régionale de santé exclu tout
risque de pénurie